Tính tôi đây, đến đây, ở đây là một người ở chủ ki.
Và tôi đây đến đây, ở đây, ở đây.
Nên đầu đừng này nó sẽ là một chủ ki.
Đây là một cách sẽ định cư bạn, à cùng biết là chủ ki sẽ là í dựa trên một dụt thì rất là.
Các bạn có ăn đây nó sẽ là có 2 đủ thì rất là trên một cái hình man như hay.
Thì làm thế nào nó sẽ định được chủ ki rất là.
Đây là thì thấy hơn đây, sẽ cho bạn một cái mẹm trong lớp của thầy.
rất nhiều cậm chí rất là pin, cho mình trong bạn cho cho các biết.
Ở làm mẹm với 3 đỉnh xa oriam, cho dựa mà mốt thời gian để cho 3 đỉnh xa oriam.
Và 3 đỉnh được chủ ki.
Thì như thế là là một cái nguyên lý cơ bạn, nó là trong bộ thị sao đâu.
Trong bộ thị hay hình xin nhạc,
và hình thị hình xin là lý tiếp, lâu thị hay hình xin cắt nhau.
Đấy làm một đợt chủ ki.
Bý mặt này không phải ăn nó chủ các bạn biết đâu.
Đây cho, và nếu như mà nó cắt nhau nè là lý tiếp,
thì khoảng ra nó trường nó trường nó trường một tây hát.
Đấy vị dụ là em hình xin lâu thị này.
Đúng không?
Chúng không phải có 2 đồ thị cắt nhau là đồ thị này.
Đồ là đồ thị này.
Cắt nhau là nó trường.
Thị khoảng ra nó xin là một đợt chủ ki.
Tức cắt nhau đó thì nó sẽ làm một đợt chủ ki.
Cám có hiểu nhau.
Ở, em có hiểu cái, tức cắt nhau.
Ở.
2 đợt chủ ki.
Để không theo 2 đợt chủ ki.
Bộ quay trang.
Còn thứ như là 3 đợt chủ ki.
Ở.
Còn thứ 3 đợt chủ ki.
Thị khoảng hình xin lâu thị này.
Đọc hình ai chờ.
Ở đây người ta không cho cái hiểu tố ký bản.
Mọi người ta cho các viết chỉ cắt nhau này.
Thị như vậy, không biết thì cho nó sẽ có 1 đợt.
Thị như thế là người nói, không?
2 đợt chủ ki.
Nào, nó sẽ là một chủ ki.
Đây là tây đi từ tây mồ để tây 2 nó làm một một người ở chủ ki.
Thị chờ.
Thế khoảng 2 đợt chủ ki.
Đây là tây 2 trụ tây mồn.
Nó sẽ bảo một nửa chủ ki.
Ở.
Và từ đây có thể là chủ ki, rồi.
chủ ki mới có mạnh phía, bây giờ.
Bây giờ rất tơ bạn.
Nếu không có lâu thị, thả tý, nếu có thể tham gà và cũng như là xem cái như video.
Hôm dẫn tiếp theo.